[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre sur
tv soixante dix huit pour cette édition
spéciale consacrée à la candidature de
paris pour les jeux olympiques de 2024
le 13 septembre prochain le comité
olympique international va rendre son
verdict la candidature française est
aujourd'hui dans la balance avec celles
des états unis et de los angeles bonjour
michaëlle jean wilfrid au cours de la
prochaine heure nous allons donc évoquer
ensemble ce dossier parisien qui fait la
part belle aux yvelines de saint quentin
en yvelines à versailles plusieurs sites
pourraient en cas de succès accueillir
des épreuves en plateau jean pierre
sauvestre vice président en charge des
sports à saint quentin en yvelines
arlon courtier directeur général
fédération française de cyclisme et
diane von carson brook escrimeuse à le
chesnay est ce qu'ils se sont dit
bonjour à tous les trois et maintenant
que les présentations sont faites voici
le sommaire de cette édition spéciale
quels sont les sites saint quentinois
retenue dans le projet paris 2024 du
golf national à la colline d'elancourt
en passant par le vélodrome et l'île des
loisirs nous irons découvrir les
équipements qui pourraient accueillir
les athlètes et le public la cité royale
également pourrait être sous les feux
des projecteurs en cas de victoire du
dossier parisien le 13 septembre
prochain cyclisme sur route dans les
rues ou encore sport équestre dans le
parc du château de versailles
et puis au delà de l'impact médiatique
quelles retombées pour le département
yvelinois les jeux vont-ils booster la
pratique sportive c'est ce nous verrons
pour être débutés êtes-vous derrière le
dossier paris 2024 soutenez-vous la
candidature française
vos réponses c'est au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude oui je suis derrière
la candidature de paris parce que je
pense que ça va permettre de créer de
l'emploi et surtout de donner une bonne
image de la ville c'est le centenaire
donc je pense que c'est une bonne chose
ça serait cool quoi si c'était un pari
mais je serai pas déçu plus que ça si
c'est pas pareil ça permet aussi à
certains jeunes de pouvoir voir autre
chose que leur vie de quartier leur vie
de tous les jours donc je trouve que
c'est vraiment intéressant ça
permettrait au club de se développer
encore plus d'avoir une visibilité
internationale
on manque un peu d'argent et donc les jo
ça coûte tellement cher
donc je sais pas vraiment pour donc pas
du tout pas du tout vraiment a pour le
coup il trop de monde trop de
l'infrastructure qui servent à rien pour
50 en yvelines la peau cité d'avoir des
bergers
les épreuves de cyclisme dans ce très
baisse dans ce très beau vélodrome donc
on attend ça avec impatience car le
courtier qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
ce micro trottoir
déjà tu surfes ans que les gens soient
autant mobilisé autour de candidature
des quelques réserves quelques fois mais
ça prouve qu'il faut continuer à
travailler à communiquer a expliqué les
bienfaits non seulement de la
candidature mais du fait nous l'espérons
tous maintenant de recevoir les jeux
olympiques à paris et à saint quentin en
yvelines en 2024 longuement non pas
surpris parce que le comité
d'organisation la candidature ait fait
un très très beau travail
le porte parole qui est tony estanguet
communique énormément
on a un très beau projet très bien bâti
financièrement raisonnable qui permet à
paris d'avoir une très belle candidature
grâce à la politique de structuration du
territoire avec des équipements qui ont
été construits depuis des années je
crois que les français sont simplement
impatient d'accueillir la plus grande
fête sportive planétaire
j'en perds semestre c'est ce que vous
ressentez sur le terrain aussi ça sur le
terrain je ressens plus de positivité
que le micro trottoir que nous avons lu
mais je suis vice-président chargé des
sports à saint quentin et donc je
fréquente des sportifs or en majorité et
donc nous attendons bien sûr avec
impatience c'est l'occasion d'accueillir
le grand événement je pense planétaire
les jeux olympiques tous les quatre ans
c'est quelque chose de planétaire et je
pense qu'à cueillir à paris et jeux
olympiques en 2024 c'est quelque chose
de très très important le territoire de
saint quentin parce que je suis vice
présidente 50 ans dont je parle plus
particulièrement du territoire de saint
quentin
c'est à une terre d'accueil de grands
événements parce que nous avons en
perspective également la ryder cup l'an
prochain nous avons également des
championnats du monde de cyclisme qui se
sont déroulés il ya deux ans les
championnats d'europe l'année dernière
en cyclisme sur piste nous avons de
grands événements et c'est l'occasion
encore d'accueillir sur notre territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines un grand
événement qui est un des plus grands
événements de planetair effectivement je
dirais aussi que c'est pour le
territoire mais au sens large pour le
département des yvelines
je pense que c'est un élan ce sera un
élan populaire dans les domaines social
dans le domaine environnemental dans le
domaine humain je pense que c'est un
élan magnifique qui doit se produire dès
le précepteur juste pour revenir sur le
micro-trottoir rapidement on a entendu
quelques réserves
même si on imagine globalement les gens
attendent ces jeux olympiques mais il ya
le rôle du politique aussi d'expliquer
parce que au-delà de l'engouement
sportif il peut y avoir des questions
légitimes sur l'avenir de certains sites
sur l'investissement que ça va
représenter
là aussi vous avez un rôle à jouer en
tant que politique oui bien sûr nous
avons un rôle à jouer en tant que
politique pour expliquer bien sûr
l'événement pour expliquer l'événement
les retombées que nous aurons également
derrière cet événement retombées
médiatiques retombées économiques bien
sûr mais d'expliquer également que c'est
pour la jeunesse pour la génération de
1024 quelque chose de très important
on pense aux adolescents actuelle en
2017 qui auront donc en 2024 l'âge
vraiment d'être athlètes de haut niveau
et participer aux jeux olympiques
et ça c'est le rôle aussi du politique
d' expliquer tout ça à la jeunesse pour
pouvoir progresser d'ici 2024
après l'obtention le 13 septembre de la
décision du comité olympique médiane
voilà exactement radial justement vous
serez peut-être participants vous êtes
participent à ces jeux ou 2024
en tant que sportif je rappelle voilà
vous avez gagné quand même léa coupe du
monde juniors dames qui sait le relais
le 17 janvier à dijon vous allez être
vice championne d'europe par équipes à
l'épée
vous avez un gros palmarès vous risquez
d'y être à cg ou 2024
mais j'aimerais beaucoup et ça me
plairait bien moi aussi je coule tu vois
plutôt des sportifs donc j'étais un
petit peu étonné par le micro trottoir
mais c'est vrai que ce serait très bien
et surtout que les scream l'événement
vraiment où les voix assez aux jo donc
c'est vraiment ça nous relancerait un
peu notre sport que ce soit les jo à
paris donc j'espère vraiment qu'on va
les obtenir parce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de super pour un port une
athlète les jeux olympiques c'est quoi
ça représente quoi un rêve c'est quand
même quelque chose d à mon avis c'est un
accomplissement rien d'y participer de
sélectionner c'est franchement le rêve
de tout athlète réponse qui plus est sur
le territoire français sur le territoire
dont on a la nationalité c'est forcément
un événement encore plus important à
vivant on va découvrir tout au long de
cette édition spéciale au cours de cette
heure les différents sites
on va peut-être partir pour le golf
national de la borde tout de suite voilà
coup de projecteur donc sur le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
structure qui accueillera déjà la ryder
cup en 2018 la coupe du monde du golf
l'équivalent la coupe du monde du golf
pourrait organiser le tournoi olympique
regardez ce reportage bien mais nous
aurons le national health it dès l'open
des phrases banales quelques semaines le
site de l'open de france mais pas
seulement la structure qui accueillera
déjà la ryder cup en 2018 l'équivalent
de la coupe du monde du golf pourrait
également recevoir les jeux olympiques
de 2024 si les dossiers parisiens est
retenu
sunshine de plus c'est une super
compétition et dans les cadres se voiler
les yoyos l'école nationale serait le
premier parcours de golf du monde andres
et world title cap et légion sa vague
d'émotion à la vie les joueurs
disputeront les parties sur le parcours
de l'albatros le 18 trous réputé comme
l'un des plus compliqués au monde a été
entièrement rénové entre 2015 et 2016
pour organiser la ryder cup
un comité olympique qui a déjà visité le
site à trois reprises se dit séduit il
n'y a pas d'autres sites comme ça au
monde
faut se rappeler que plus que un golf
c'est un stade de golf
c'est vrai qu'ici tout a été pensé pour
les joueurs oui un parcours exceptionnel
mais aussi pour les spectateurs et donc
on ne retrouve pas un goal de ce type là
au monde donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons cette force qui est la nôtre
de pouvoir accueillir de grandes
compétitions et surtout avec un parcours
exceptionnel les routes nationales ça ce
n'est pas inquiétant car on a on a placé
les prix mais c'est qu'au lycée on a un
hôtel on en parle coller des top niveau
et donc à nos polos ça ce n'est pas ça
ce n'est pas un propos patients forts de
leurs 24 open de france organisé depuis
l'ouverture du site en 1990 les
dirigeants ont mis en avant leur
expérience des grandes compétitions pour
convaincre le cio la ryder cup 2018
permettra de se roder une nouvelle fois
aux événements internationaux à 6 ans
des jo où l'effet dawala rayak à son
avantage pour n'importe quoi pour venir
dans les futures c'est comme elle à la
plus grande compétition de gaulle du
monde
est on est on est très fiers de recevoir
la ryder cup et on n'a pas douté que ça
répondrait aussi il y aune travaille
très dur pour ça le golf national
pourrait accueillir entre 35 et 40 mille
personnes sur le site pour les jeux
olympiques deux fois moins de
spectateurs que pour la ryder cup 2018
jean pierre sauvestre vice président
chargé des sports donc sur saint quentin
en yvelines on parlera tout à l'heure du
vélodrome et je ne veut froisser
personne mais le golf national c'est
aussi un écran est un des atouts de
cette candidature parisienne au final
c'est un des atouts essentiels de cette
candidature aux jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 il faut pas
oublier non plus et c'est un parcours
magnifique un parcours magnifique dans
un cadre extraordinaire et le président
est effectivement de saint-quentin l'a
précisé dans son interview
nous avons accueilli la semaine dernière
l'open de france et ce fut une réussite
vraiment que cette compétition la ryder
cup va compléter encore la visite de ce
parcours de ce parcours magnifique et
donc nous allons pouvoir pour les jeux
olympiques à voir je dirai au cours des
différentes aux événements essentiels et
à très très important nous allons
pouvoir accueillir les jeux olympiques
en 2024 de façon très rodé je dirais et
le golf est quelque chose de très
important au sein du territoire
nous avons énormément d'initiation des
élèves déjeunent 3000 élèves ont été
initiés au cours des quatre à cinq
dernières années et nous continuerons
d'aider des initiations des séances de
golf pour les élèves de cours moyen
première année comme moyen deuxième
année des élèves qui sont passionnés par
le golfe et qui accroche sur ce sport
donc c'est un sport au sein de saint
quentin qui a une importance c'est ce
que j'allais vous demandez aussi le
travail que vous pouvez éventuellement
mener avec alors peut-être on parlera de
la fédération de cyclisme aussi mais la
fédération de golf vous travaillez pour
tout à fait
il y ait cet engouement
là nous travaillons avec la fédération
française de golf et puis sans oublier
les associations sur saint quentin qui
sont très volontaires pour faire une
initiation pour permettre aux élèves de
connaître ce sport il y à différents
différentes activités comme croco golf
une mallette pédagogique également qui
permet aux élèves d'aborder certaines
disciplines via le golfe
c'est très ludique et donc ça permet des
initiations et donc nous avons une
volonté de rendre le golf
je dirais un peu moins élitiste parce
qu'il a encore une image effectivement
un peu délité de un peu un peu haute
je dirais de le rendre un peu plus un
peu plus possible pour le grand public
le privé
pour parler plus globalement du coup
d'oeil ou 2024 selon les médias
américains le dossier de los angeles
serait déjà hors course pour accueillir
les jo de 2024
on se dirigerait vers une double
attribution à halima 11 septembre 2024
pour paris et 2028 pour los angeles
est-ce qu'on a raison d'y croire nos
courtiers j'espère il n'arrive peut être
aussi optimiste vis on a de bonnes
raisons d'être optimiste on connaît
notre dossier il est excellent c'est
reconnu de tous
il est évident aussi que la symbolique
de 924 2024 s'entend après des derniers
jeux d'été en france ce serait quand
même extrêmement forte
je voudrais juste faire une petite
parenthèse par rapport au golf national
il faut aussi saluer la vision de saint
quentin en yvelines et de la fédération
française de golf à l'époque un parcours
qui a été inaugurée en bout sans pardon
1990 donc dans les cartons un peu avant
la vision d'origine de ce parcours
c'était d'être un site olympique et
d'accueillir la ryder cup parce que le
président de la fédération française de
golf de l'époque claude roger quartier a
oeuvré toute sa vie pour le retour du
golf aux jeux olympiques et pour avoir
la ryder cup en france donc envoyé par
email de fond ça c'est pas du tout ça ça
vient de loin il ya un travail de fond
c'est la même chose pour le vélodrome
nationale qui est sorti de terre grâce à
la volonté et de saint quentin en
yvelines et de notre fédération
à l'origine il faisait partie du dossier
la candidate aussi de la nature 2012
mais qui va pleinement servir les jeux
2024 diane vous y croyez pour aux
jo-2000 24 à paris mais je pense qu'on a
on a de bonnes raisons d'y croire ce
qu'on a décidé absolument fabuleux quoi
je pense pas que los angeles puis se
montrer autant d'histoires avec tous
leurs sites
donc j'espère vraiment qu'on va les
abords le 5 juillet dernier justement
wilfried le rapport 282 pages publié par
le cio a qualifié la candidature
parisienne d'incroyable avec un cadre
époustouflant
suite à ces visites en mai dernier los
angeles s'est lui aussi qualifié de
candidature voilà importante magnifique
mais est ce que jean-pierre serait c'est
ce que ce mot époustouflant peut faire
pencher la balance peut-être puis les
visites sur le terrain visiteur à
sébastien moreira le 15 mai se sont très
bien passées avec les experts du cio
effectivement quand tu étais content été
étonnés presque 2 du niveau de
prestations et ça n'est pas seulement au
niveau du territoire du département mais
je pense que la france se présente
effectivement avec des sportifs de haut
niveau qui connaissent très bien et je
citerai encore l'historien est donc des
personnes qui connaissent très bien
qu'ils supportent ce dossier de façon
magnifique et nous sur le territoire
nous avons aussi nous nous sommes
engagés dès le départ dans les instances
de travail pour paris 2024 avec les avec
le groupe
le gip et et nous sommes partenaires
entier est très très volontaire sur
cette candidature
il n'y a pas d'excès de confiance parce
qu'il ya une grosse déception en 2012 on
va pas revenir sur les épisodes est
délicate difficile mais néanmoins il
faut toujours apprendre de ses erreurs
il ya eu un excès de confiance à
l'époque là aujourd'hui
oui mais je pense que c'était une
compétition nous sommes nous sommes dans
le sport et dans le sport il y avait une
finale et la finale ce sont deux là deux
candidatures los angeles et paris et il
ya effectivement un vainqueur mais je
pense que
nous ne serons pas déçus le courtier
cette double candidature c'est une bonne
résolution de la part du cio
ça serait une bonne décision oui ce
serait probablement une bonne décision
il faut bien voir qu'il ya donc un
changement puisqu'il n'y a là plus que
deux candidats ce qui change la donne
pour le cio les enjeux des années à
venir et particulièrement d'un point de
vue économique sont très importants les
jeux olympiques coûte cher et il y avait
une véritable inflation voit ce qui se
passe actuellement aussi sur
l'organisation de tokyo des vrais
problèmes économiques
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'à une prise
de conscience que les candidatures les
dossiers organisation des jeux soit
vraiment raisonnée et raisonnable et je
pense que paris pourrait marquer un
tournant à ce niveau là en organisant
des jeux raisonnée et raisonnable mais
pour autant dans un cadre époustouflant
celui de paris et de la région ile de
france
c'est ce qui permettrait d'avoir des
jeux finalement l'ambiance des jeux dans
la ville de sentir cette atmosphère même
si on n'est pas forcément dans un stade
donc ça c'est vraiment particulier et
avoir des événements à paris sur le
champ de mars au château de versailles à
elancourt sur la colline voilà c'est une
ouverture au plus grand nombre
absolument extraordinaire
cette édition spéciale sûreté 60,18 se
poursuit et j'allais faire la petite
erreur
vous l'aurez relevé j'allais dire
téléfilm en tv 78 vous le savez
dorénavant la chaîne a évolué dans son
dans son nom tv 78 2 vous propose cette
édition spéciale
en attendant cette annonce le 13
septembre du cio pour la candidature est
des jeux olympiques de 2024 si nous
parlons des différents sites nous irons
à versailles nous parlerons aussi
peut-être de l'accompagnement des
sportifs voir comment les sportifs
peuvent se préparer dans le cadre de
jeux olympiques est ce que les
structures ont un rôle à jouer
la structure politique locale aussi pour
accompagner ces différents sportifs
auparavant un focus sur le vélodrome
charles vélodrome effectivement la
structure sorti tard en 2014 pour 70 1
millions d'euros a déjà accueilli des
grandes compétitions internationales une
expérience qui lui permet d'être l'un
des points forts de la candidature
parisienne
regardez ce sujet le vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et déjà
prêts à accueillir les jeux olympiques
seul projet francilien avoir survécu à
la candidature de paris 2012
la structure a officiellement été
inauguré en janvier 2014
depuis cette date le site s'éroder en
organisant les championnats du monde
cyclisme sur piste en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante
une expérience qui a impressionné le cio
pendant son passage
bien sûr ça lève le doute sur sur toutes
les interrogations qu'on pourrait avoir
la l'équipement il est là il a été testé
et il a accueilli déjà la plus grandes
échéances internationales avec les
championnats du monde donc je pense que
tout ça c'est forcément des garanties
pour pour le seuil haut pour accueillir
les supporters pendant les jo 5000
places ont été construites dans la
structure on a une proximité avec la
piste voilà puisque au delà de la
balustrade les le public est juste là il
peut être un match finalement des
coureurs qui passent avec des vitesses
élevées un des coureurs qui atteignent
70 quasiment 80 km heure sur les
épreuves de sprint
donc voilà toute cette ambiance et ce
show très spectaculaire sur la piste
avec le public généralement et et et
soutien et supporter grandement ses
athlètes
le spectacle se passe également sous la
piste les 250 m pour 8 de large sont
entretenus régulièrement pour mettre les
athlètes dans les meilleures conditions
ses références et donc on voit à quel
niveau on mais puisque par exemple en
cas de chute on peut être amené à
remplacer des tasseaux de bois sur
lesquels les coureurs roulent par le
dessous donc voilà on peut essayer de se
repérer là on voit que bien sûr on est
dans une courbe donc dans un des deux
virages 2
de la piste une charpente en bois qui
est déjà marquée par les performances
des pistards tricolore sur la piste du
vélodrome nationale là bas on à grégory
baugé multiple champion du monde qui
était au dernier chez aux derniers jeux
olympiques
quentin lafargue médaillé de bronze ici
aux championnats du monde sur piste
là on à michael d'almeida qui
multiple médaillé olympique la nouvelle
génération rêve sans doute d'imiter
leurs aînés en inscrivant leur nom sur
les poutres du vélodrome après une
médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
la dédicace sera peut être programmé
pour 2024
alors le courtier ce vélodrome il devait
accueillir les jo de 2012 finalement
2024 mais on sera parfaitement prêt pour
comme on le voit dans le reportage on a
organisé des championnats du monde en
l'année dernière nous avons organisé des
championnats d'europe
sans dévoiler de secret nous sommes
candidats à l'accueil d'une manche de
coupe du monde en 2018 javelodrome rodez
c'est un vélodrome rodez parfaitement
taillé pour ce type d'événements
internationaux
c'est un vélodrome apprécié des athètes
ça c'est très important
c'est vraiment les retours qu'on a eus
apprécié aussi bien dans sa dans sa
structure et donc dans son utilisation
que pour la qualité de sa piste on a une
piste rapide
donc c'est un vieux grenier une bonne
réputation auprès des athlètes
donc tout est prêt il ne nous manque
plus que les choses allaient à pic alors
voilà alors qu'il est finalement assez
récemment et et si tout se passe bien
ouverture 2014 et jeux olympiques dix
ans après pas mal et c'est le seul
dossier qui a survécu du coup aux jo de
2012 tout à fait c'était là c'est la
sortie nature à paris ce jour la seule
infrastructure planifié par rapport à la
candidature de 2012 qui soit sorti de
terre tant mieux ça répond parfaitement
aujourd'hui aux besoins et aux cahiers
des charges l'organisation des jeux pour
2024 y avait une volonté politique de
justement voir cette structure naître
malgré l'échec de 2002 il y avait une
volonté politique
après l'échec de la candidature de
londres de de faire naître cet
équipement qui est remarquable qui est
remarquable j'ai assisté à la dernière
compétition et c'est quelque chose d'une
ambiance extraordinaire au sein de ce
vélodrome et qu'il faut qu'il faut faire
vivre effectivement parce que nous avons
la perspective des jeux olympiques y en
attendant nous avons il nous faut des
compétitions effectivement sur ce
vélodrome pour le faire vivre
et puis pour avoir pouvoir d'aider à
tête des athètes également je pense que
nous avons une nouvelle équipe
maintenant qu'ils qui relève l'ancien
très bonne équipe que nous avions et
pour les jeux olympiques effectivement
nous aurons un équipement qui
correspondra aux attentes mais en dehors
du vélodrome nous avons la colline
d'elancourt
oui vous avez également où nous allons
peut-être aborder le sujet tout à fait
rappaz de la colline de l'encours de
l'île des loisirs désire également donc
je ne vais pas parler tout de suite mais
effectivement il ya d'autres équipements
pour le centrisme sur le territoire pour
pour parler du dut revenir sur le
vélodrome est sûre le boost que ça
pourrait entraîner parce qu'on parle de
focus médiatique pendant les jeux
olympiques mais au delà de ça ce serait
un véritable engouement qui est qui
pourrait naître autour du du vélo à
saint quentin en yvelines ont créé un
peu plus le vélodrome sur le territoire
aussi le faire connaître le faire
connaître encore plus il est déjà connu
il est clairement ancré c'est important
de le dire parce que j'en discutais de
l'autre jour avec le directeur du cher
le site du vélodrome depuis son
ouverture donc on vient de passer les
dix mille baptême lady midi initiation
sur piste c'est important il ya déjà
plus de dix mille personnes qui sont
venues pour la première fois de leur vie
rouler sur une piste on parlait tout à
l'heure de avec escrime de sport
olympique de sport qu'on ne voit pas
forcément tout le temps la piste est un
sport olympique clairement qu'ils
méritent plus d'imagés plus d'audience
parce que c'est un spectacle c'est un
show absolument fantastique
maintenant il est évident que la venue
des jeux d'un point de vue sportif et
d'un point de vue plus globalement
économique parce que le vélodrome est
multifonction il sert aussi à
l'organisation de séminaires de
conférences de tels événements donc
c'est évidemment le mettre sur le devant
de la scène le promouvoir et donc
le faire connaître aussi bien au grand
public qu'aux sportifs qu'aux
entreprises et aux médias et donc le
faire fonctionner encore plus pleinement
tout au long de l'année
avant de parler des deux autres sites de
saint quentin en yvelines j'aurais juste
quelques 4 qu'on fasse une petite
parenthèse avec l'athlète qui est avec
est avec nous et joue dans le cadre
justement de ces jeux olympiques
l'attribution ou non à paris vous
pourriez en tout cas y participer est ce
qu'il ya un accompagnement spécifique
qui se met déjà en place et ce que les
jeux olympiques on en parle lors des des
différentes compétitions se dit il faut
que je sois performante est ce qu'on s'y
prépare déjà avant même de savoir mais
forcément avant avant paris aurait forcé
- tokyo
donc on s'y prépare oui on sait qu'on
doit faire des comptes va faire des
belles compétitions pour être bien
classé pour pouvoir y parvenir un jour
donc on se prépare en fait tous les
jours c'est tous les jours à
l'entraînement tous les jours quand
quand on se relâche tous les jours on y
pense et si vraiment important pour nous
c'est l'objectif l'accomplissement que
d'y participer
pour l'instant le jeu d'un fort sens de
plus en tant que jeune encore une
concentre plus je vois plus loin tous
vers paris mais c'est vrai que tokyo est
quand même là et on le sent par les
grandes avec qui je vais m'entraîner
prochaine on le sait elles s'attendent
que c'est andré s'entraîner avec elle
parce qu'il ya un accompagnement et un
suivi une aide aussi parce qu'être
sportif est sportif de haut niveau c'est
aussi un budget beaucoup de sacrifices
financièrement est ce que les là pour le
coup les politiques aussi les assauts et
les structures sportives remplissent
leur rôle vous êtes aussi bas du coup je
m'entraînais à bord 12 août l'année
dernière et là je vais passer à l'insep
et
ils ont vraiment des structures
fabuleuse on peut pas rêver mieux
il ya tout donc dans l'insep et tahoua
séduire qui est lui aussi au fleuret et
donc pour ça c'est vraiment génial on
peut s'entraîner dans de très bonnes
conditions
et là ce sera bien après nous ce sera au
grand palais les scream cissé à paris
donc c'est temporaire donc ça nous
apportera pas grand chose mais au niveau
du budget je pense que ça va être très
intéressant au niveau des politiques
aussi vous accompagner vous aider ces
sportifs ces structures associatives
sportives de haut niveau et puis
peut-être aussi les amateurs parce que
eux ils vont aussi afflué en général en
effet chez les amateurs aussi et au sein
du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines nous avons 400 associations
sportives et nous avons effectivement
une crique et risation sur les athlètes
de haut niveau que nous essayons d'aider
au maximum mais il ya d'autres critères
également de dead et de subventions aux
associations sportives que nous
soutenons le mieux possible
effectivement et en perspective des jeux
olympiques nous aurons encore plus
d'attention vis-à-vis de nos
associations sportives bien sûr
associations sportives qui présente
également parfois des particularités et
je pense notamment parce qu'ils se sont
je ré insiste un petit peu sur les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et nous
avons au sein du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
effectivement nous avons souci d'aider
effectivement à l'intégration des
personnes qui ont débuté des difficultés
à rentrer dans les associations que ce
soit pour le vélodrome pour le vélo le
golf mais pour toute activité permettre
d'aider les associations qui vont vers
les personnes en difficulté notamment
physique ou autre pays parce qu'une fois
que les olympiques seront terminés les
jeux paralympiques prendront la relève
juste derrière jeux paralympiques
prendront la relève et je pense à la
réflexion de
de diane c'est nous avons peut-être nous
politiques une réflexion sur 2024 paris
2024 mais la réflexion effectivement
d'athlètes actuelle si tokyo
c'est de dire le peuvent c'est ce sont
les futurs jeux olympiques et peut-être
ensuite paris mais si ce n'est pas paris
ce sera faite à los angeles pour vous
donc pour un athlète c'est toujours
quatre ans et une olympiade mais
qu'importe tout ça se trouve où ça se
déroule mais si c'est sur place ces
textes c'est encore mieux avec 121
bouder notre plaisir
alors nous allons partir maintenant à la
découverte du troisième site dans les
yvelines qui pourrait accueillir les
jeux olympiques 2024 coup de projecteur
sur la colline d'elancourt le point
culminant d'île de france pourrait
accueillir les épreuves de vtt
regardez la colline tellancourt
deviendra t elle enfin une colline
olympique loup projets dans les cartons
depuis les jo de 2012 a été ressortie
pour la candidature de paris aux jo de
le site qui culmine à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude fait toujours autant
l'unanimité auprès des organisateurs
pour accueillir les épreuves de vtt
la première force et l'unité de lieu le
deuxième point là ici c'est la
dénivellation et donc le vtt on appelle
ça mountain bike c'est du vélo de
montagne et donc il faut aller chercher
à des pentes raides et il ya quasiment
qu'ici qu'on a qu'on a ce que l'on
souhaite pour avoir à quelque chose de
très raide donc oui c'est assez naturel
que ça vienne ici sur la sur la colline
de la range pour rendre ce site
totalement opérationnel pour les jeux
olympiques quelques travaux sont
nécessaires dans ce lieu à l'état
presque sauvage des tribunes seront
construites en amont de la colline les
organisateurs vont également devoir
façonner un parcours entre 4 et 6 km
avec des sentiers des secteurs
goudronnées des partis en sous-bois pour
répondre au cahier des charges
cet aménagement c'est pas pour
construire c'est vraiment pour modeler
donc on va on le fait avec avec des
rochers
de la pierre avec du gore avec avec
également des troncs d'arbres on est
vraiment dans du modelage donc on peut
le faire avec des produits sur place
avec des gravats également le vtt reste
quand même une discipline de pleine
nature et on joue avec ce que l'on a ce
qu'on en a sous les pieds pour
construire ce parcours d'une durée d'une
heure trente les organisateurs pourrait
s'appuyer sur les clubs locaux et
notamment le vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisateurs
de la revanchard d'une épreuve de vtt
qui fêtera cette année ses 19 ans on a
notre idée sur les aspects techniques
mais j'espère qu'on pourra solliciter
les acteurs locaux on a des clubs qui
sont mobilisés des clubs locaux qui est
dans la pratique du vtt sont sont
également très présents et ils
connaissent mieux les lieux que
n'importe qui ici donc certainement
qu'ils doivent bien les connaître et
donc c'est ça sera plus de s'appuyer sur
leur connaissance du terrain
le coût total de l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt pour les jo n'est
pas encore connue si le cio désignera
france en septembre prochain
les premiers coups de pioche pourrait
être donné d'ici 2020 et s'il est un
point important dans cette candidature
de paris 2024 c'est que peut-être enfin
sur cette colline del encore il y aura
quelque chose qui va voir le jour
voila voila fait tout à fait je pense
que mon 2012 n'était pas opérationnel
mais 2024 je pense permettra d'aménager
cette colline avec un parcours olympique
donc un parcours de qualité qui devra
répondre bien sûr certains critères
présenté par le cio des critères
notamment de télétransmission et cetera
puisque nous avons les médias
d'importance sur les sur les épreuves
olympiques et mais je pense qu'il nous
faut réaliser un parcours qui répondent
également aux critères aux critères
écologiques aux critères de
développement durable sur cette colline
et je pense que c'est très réalisable
dans l'esprit olympique réalisé un
parcours comme il a été précisé est de
5,6 km qui permettent d'avoir des
épreuves de qualité et qui permettent de
garder un site également de qualités qui
permettent de garder la biodiversité de
leleu le caractère le caractère comme il
est dit dans le dans le reportage de
caractère un peu sauvage de cette
colline de le conserver tout de même
après les jeux olympiques
est-ce que l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines à la main ou en tout
cas un droit de regard sur le dossier
parce que là on parlait des sites
jusqu'à présent qui existait déjà que ce
soit le golf national ou le vélodrome
l'a le site n'existe pas encore n'a pas
été aménagées est-ce que vous avez un
droit de regard bien bien ça nous sommes
partenaires nous sommes partenaires la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin avec la ville d'elancourt
et bien sûr et avec les différents
partenaires avec la fédération française
de cyclisme bien sûr pour l'aménagement
de cette colline et pour répondre aux
critères et pour faire quelque chose de
remarquable en 2024
oui mais sur l'aspect financier parce
que il ya une incidence ou non sur
l'aspect financier il y aura une
incidence effectivement légère mais
c'est le cio qui assure tout de même là
elle prendre partie du financement
et comme il est dit le financement n'est
pas encore totalement fixé par le
courtier on l'a entendue dans le
reportage
la fédération française veut peut-être
s'appuyer sur les clubs locaux pour
construire un parcours digne de ce nom
est ce que c'est une bonne idée oui
c'est une bonne idée d'autant que comme
on vient de l'évoquer c'est un travail
collaboratif
parce que au delà même des jeux qui sont
l'objectif est il ya une vision
d'héritage l aménagement de la colline
d'elancourt ce n'est pas que pour les
jeux c'est pour avant pendant et après
des jeux la fédération française ziclean
avec l'ouverture du vélodrome s'est
implantée à saint quentin
yvelines et de manière durable nous
sommes donc en phase de développement de
ski et le centre national du cyclisme
puisque nous avons une piste que nous
avons une piste de bmx couverte pour
l'entraînement toute l'année nous aurons
l'aménagement de la colline d'elancourt
donc pour la partie vtt le mountain bike
et puis toutes les routes de la région
et la vallée de chevreuse pour le pour
la route tout simplement ou aussi pour
notre discipline pour l'entraînement
donc le travail avec les clubs il est
important parce que ils vont pouvoir
derrière utiliser cet aménagement de
manière très très durable et comme il
fait tilt dans le reportage ils ont une
très grande connaissance des lieux donc
plutôt que de risquer de commettre des
erreurs autant partager avec eux leur
demander leur avis prendre conseils et
s'appuient sur leurs connaissances
diane les sportifs ont leur mot à dire
dans ce dossier parisien
parce qu'on vous a consulté vous par
exemple on m'a pas consulté
personnellement je pense que c'est
plutôt les grands fonction des derniers
jeux olympiques qui ont leur mot à dire
mais après je pense que tout conseil
peut être bon à prendre puisque le
sportif s'est quand même celui qui va
qui va aller sur la structure est celui
qui qui doit être en bonne position pour
gagner je pense qu'on a notre mot à dire
zoom maintenant sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines le site
pourrait accueillir une nouvelle piste
de bmx provisoire à côté du vélodrome
national de 50 ans les mines si la
france est retenue chez eux pour
organiser l'épreuve
regardez ce terrain vague de sept
hectares pourrait se transformer en
stadium de bmx dans les prochaines
années l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines a été retenue dans le
dossier paris 2024 pour accueillir les
épreuves masculines et féminines de ce
sport extrême
ce site a été choisi principalement
parce qu'ils jour je te le vélodrome on
est on est à 100 mètres à pied du
vélodrome
donc il y aura une parfaite qu'on peut
le complémentarité entre les épreuves
qui se dérouleront dans le vélodrome et
les épreuves de bmx ici sans parler du
cadre nature qui s'y prête parfaitement
exit donc l'actuel stadium de bmx situé
à côté du vélo tour national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le parcours n'est pas aux normes
olympiques autre point noir le toit à
structure métallique peut gêner la
télévision pour les plans aériens
le stadium servira donc de piste
d'entraînement
les athlètes pourront s'échauffer sur la
piste de bmx actuelle avant de venir
concourir ici et c'est vraiment tout ça
je vous dis encore une fois dans un
environnement de une centaine de mètres
donc tout pourra se faire à pied sans
problème pour correspondre cette fois ci
au cahier des charges olympique le
nouveau site aura une piste provisoire
comprise entre 400 et 450 m les tribunes
d'augmenter également pouvoir accueillir
plusieurs milliers de personnes
d'importants travaux sont donc à prévoir
c'est le comité olympique qui va
exactement définir les surfaces dont ils
ont besoin notamment des places de
parking parce que comme on espère
beaucoup beaucoup de visiteurs il faudra
des places de parking il y en a déjà
mais c'est pas suffisant
donc voilà c'est tout c'est un gros
projet quand même puisqu'il va sortir de
terre cette future piste est accueilli
comme une bonne nouvelle par l'équipe de
france de bmx médaillés d'or et d'argent
aux jo de 2008
pour les bleus c'est 2 stadium seront un
plus dans la quête de nouveaux titres
olympiques en 2024 pour l'entraînement
ça représente
après deux superbes outils sur lesquels
on peut diversifier justement les
entraînements si tu peux les aider à
progresser encore un petit peu plus
maintenant sur le fait voilà la compet
de la faire sur une autre piste
ils seront prêts quoi qu'il arrive à moi
que ce soit sur celle là ou sur une
autre encore une fois le job ça sera le
même si la france est retenue par le
comité olympique en septembre les
premières consultations seront lancés
d'ici la fin de l'année et travaux
pourraient eux débuter d'ici 2020 alors
juste avant de revenir sur l'îlot azir
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
l'accueil du coût des épreuves de bmx on
va écouter laura flessel qui elle était
et à l'open de france de golf et elle
parle justement de la candidature
parisienne de pour le 2024 et lorsqu'on
voit à gérer les infrastructures
l'aménagement l'état participaient aussi
l'année prochaine on aura une belle
ryder cup c'est le sait le troisième
événement plus importance pour nous
c'est très important en vue de gérer en
vue aussi des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques donc voilà ce sont des
événements qu'on s'est organisée donc il
faut le dire aussi à l'international
jean pierre sauvestre on a les deux cas
de figure on a voilà le golf national
qui accueille chaque année l'open de
france qu'il va accueillir la ryder cup
en 2018
et de l'autre côté il y allait de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines où
il faudra construire une structure
provisoire
on a vraiment deux cas de figure
vraiment opposés dans 2 15 dossiers au
vraiment différent mais je voudrais
revenir un peu sur l'île de loisirs qui
est un espace vraiment remarquable avec
une réserve naturelle avec le premier
plan d'eau en point de vue et qualité de
l'eau et puis grandeur de la région
parisienne et donc nous avons un espace
qui est vraiment extraordinaire avec
également le golfe
et puis diverses activités donc lille de
loisirs est quelque chose de très
important
sur notre territoire mais également pour
toute la région et les communes
limitrophes et d'accueillir une piste de
bmx sur ce site je pense va permettre de
compléter l'offre de la région avec le
vélodrome
effectivement la colline d'elancourt et
puis la piste bmx qui ne sera que pour
les jeux olympiques c'est une
réalisation je pense doute semblable à
celle de riom et je me souviens de la
piste doriot c'était vraiment une piste
remarquable alors je pense que pour les
jeux olympiques il y aura sur les
loisirs où il y à l'espace on cite des
le reportage le panda première le
premier message c'est un terrain vague
j'aime pas tellement le l'expression sur
les terrains vagues lorsqu'on parle un
petit peu de l'île de loisirs parce que
c'est un espace de réserve naturelle
c'est un espace à conserver et donc à
l'accueil de la piste de bmx sera
vraiment quelque chose d'important
donc ça sera forcément provisoire cette
piste se serait forcément provisoire est
effectivement la piste sera réalisé par
le comité olympique et non pas par les
collectivités locales
parlons de saint quentin en yvelines on
va parler de versailles dans un instant
auparavant juste peut-être un petit tour
de table votre plus beau souvenir
olympique est moins marqué les uns les
autres
plein de choses parce que je suis plus
tout jeune donc des jeux olympiques j'en
ai vu quelques-uns à la télé c'est pas
un souvenir précis c'est un souvenir
global finalement c'est l'émotion donc
procure cet événement et qu'on soit
sportif ou pas on peut rester chez soi
est devant sa télé et on ressent
l'émotion deux champions de sportifs de
nos athlètes
parfois des milliers de kilomètres de
distance et ils nous font vibrer on
l'attend on attend les jeux olympiques
avec une grande impatience on y voit des
disciplines qu'on y voit qu'on voit
rarement
moi j'adore regarder le le plongeon par
exemple quand elles ont appris qu on en
voit rarement et pourtant c'est
magnifique
et voilà et donc on ça permet aux aux
plus jeunes de découvrir des sports vous
avez parlé d'affluence derrière
effectivement ça déclenche a des envies
les médaillés ce sont des pratiquants et
des licenciés en plus pour les
fédérations dans la foulée donc c'est
très important donc c'est l'émotion
globale que procurent les jeux
olympiques
un souvenir de jeux olympiques je pense
qu'elle verrait bien moins car le
courtier oui non mais j'ai refusé
souvenir de rio tout de suite mais je
pense que après l'échec de l'ong
allemande de l'escrim avec zéro médaille
a rapporté à rio dans la rapporter 3 et
je pense que quand j'ai vu les l'épée
hommes par équipes gagnent et ça a été
vraiment un très bon souvenir
1 re lancement un peu de notre sport
aussi je pense a glissé médaille ça vous
a donné envie et peut-être de vous
lancer dans l'escrimé est est très très
bonne que un petit peu on m'a dit c'est
un bon courage
jean pierre sauvestre souvenirs
olympiques alors manger les amarres
qu'elle ait donné un coup de vieux à
l'assemblée mais ce sont des images de
télévision en noir et blanc avec zidane
jazzy si vous voulez à tokyo par exemple
allié à l'époque ce sont des souvenirs
extraordinaires parce que il y avait les
motions effectivement de la
retransmission
mais il y avait les motions du champion
français étaient arrivés et médaillée
d'or et c'est extraordinaire
voilà c'est c'est un souvenir il ya eu
d'autres souvenirs depuis mais c'est un
souvenir d'enfance venir en plus voilà
par les deux champions français
effectivement il faut pas oublier cette
dimension patriotique autour des baisers
d'un événement olympique et de de
soutien d'une nation derrière ces
athlètes on quitte saint quentin en
yvelines
pendant quelques minutes on y reviendra
ensuite en fin d'émission pour parler de
cette soirée cette journée du 13
septembre que vous vivrez d'ailleurs sur
tv fil 78 en direct pendant l' annonce
est du cio on part pour versailles pour
l'instant effectivement wilfried la
commune organisée le 23 juin dernier une
journée spéciale tournée vers les jeux
olympiques en partenariat avec le club
d'athlétisme de la ville au stade un mot
boron programme de la perche du lancer
de javelot ou encore des courses de la
catégorie cadets à vétérans une centaine
de sportifs a participé à la
manifestation
je suis allé à sur place pour rencontrer
l'adjoint aux sports de la ville de
versailles jean marc fresnel nous parle
évidemment de la candidature
versaillaise
la ville de versailles veut accueillir
les jeux olympiques et le prouve sur le
terrain ce vendredi 23 juin au stade
mont boron une journée spéciale dédiée
aux valeurs de l'olympisme est organisée
au programme des épreuves d'athlétisme
et pour parler de cette journée
exceptionnelle nous avons jean-marc
fresnel adjoint au maire à versailles au
sport
jean-marc fresnel pourquoi avoir
organisé cet événement ici à versailles
ce vendredi 23 juin alors pourquoi déjà
le nom parce que le 23 juin c'est la
journée de l'olympisme depuis très
longtemps j'ai découvert c'est depuis
1948 donc je pense on a faim toujours
été présent tout le temps mais surtout
bombe à versailles est très impliquée
dans la candidature de paris
parce que d'abord on est en région
parisienne dans l'ensemble des communes
je pensais de dunes mouvement sportif
parisien se mobilisent autour des tests
événements et puis surtout nous aurons
des épreuves importantes parce que
toutes les épreuves d'hippisme seront à
versailles dans le château certes mais à
versailles et puis également tous les
épreuves de cyclisme sur route
ce qu'on peut dire c'est versailles est
un peu une terre d une terre de cyclisme
des yvelines une terre des yvelines du
cycliste dire pardon et que
c'est pour ça que donc le comité
d'organisation a à penser mettre les
épreuves de contre-la-montre les
épreuves sur route contre-la-monte
partant de paris arriveront versailles
arrivé à versailles devant le château
et puis le épreuves sur route sur le
même circuit mais avec plusieurs boucles
en vallée de chevreuse et ensuite le
retour à paris dans une configuration
type tour de france et c'était plutôt
votre idée cet événement où l'idée de du
club d'athlétisme de versailles alors
les deux mois je pense que d'une part
cette partie cette journée à paris paris
voulant faire quelque chose de
particulier enfin et on l'a vu la piste
ce matin et demain vraiment quels
efforts énormes pour être fait pour cela
mais aussi en disant ben cette journée
là comment nous toutes les autres villes
on peut on peut contribuer le club est
venu tout de suite nous voir en disant
on va nous
pourquoi pas rentrer dans cette
dynamique là en général au mois de juin
on a un meeting autant de calais ce
jour-là et et puis voilà toute la
mayonnaise a pris et nous ça nous a
semblé bien parce que l'athlétisme c'est
quand même le sport de base de la clé de
l'olympisme et puis c'est tout un tas de
valeur voilà qu'on peut tous associés
plein de choses autour parce que c'est
pas uniquement des coureurs c'est la fin
des lanceurs des sauteurs accélère donc
voilà c'est le symbole olympique et je
pense très fort on a une installation
marcano 6 à versailles ici et puis à
partir du monde le club est partie sur
ces dynamiques moi je trouve que dire
d'un comment on peut peut-être associer
d'autres événements avec les jeunes et
scolaires les lycées les collèges et
puis et on va être en parler aussi un
petit peu ce qu'on développe en fin
d'après-midi et l' enthousiasme ça peut
faire pencher la balance vraiment alors
moi je suis en contact assez fréquents
avec les l'organisation fait le comité
de
l'un pic et ils sont très gênés revu ce
matin mais vraiment c'est très bien ce
que vous faites à versailles puisqu'on
ya aussi des challenges chronométrés
enfin par rapport à d'autres événements
c'était le go sport et puis paris
versailles
donc maintenant on savait il ya des
applications aux mesures nos kilomètres
on les associe etc
donc on est rentré dans ses derniers
dynamique et je pense qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de villes qui ont qui sont
partis sur ces sujets là donc c'est bien
je pense que le comité d'organisation
voit que versailles est présent
dynamique savez je crois que les jeux
olympiques
certes si l événement qui est un
événement qui va être important
mais au delà de l'événement c'est tout
ce qu'on va faire entre maintenant entre
limal 13 septembre
et puis elle après et puis le premier le
premier jour des jeux c'est que comme on
montre qu'on est une api une ville mais
fait un environnement sportif comment on
peut encore plus le développer quel type
de sport il faut dynamiser parce que
peut-être que on a besoin de sortir un
peu du du canevas clubs compétitions etc
comment apporter du sport à socialement
à tout un tas de populations qui en sont
un petit peu l'ont éloignée
et puis moi ce que je trouve et moi je
suis un des premiers on sait josé on est
jeune on est vieux à ces jeunes où on
est jeune on est des vieux à ces jeunes
et même on a nos âges moi mon âge on a
envie se mesurer de ce qu'on ne mettrait
de progresser donc on a
pourquoi pas un accompagnement à faire
et je pense que nous si rôle ville c'est
aussi ce qu'on doit faire auprès de la
population
en tout cas les athlètes qui sont juste
derrière nous sur ultra motivés on
écoute justement ce micro trottoir
réalisé par patrick jacques de dixmude
ça donnera une occasion pour aller pour
aller voir et puis ça fait toujours du
plaisir d'avoir une compétition en
france et a pas mal de choses dans le
coin donc ça va être ça va être très
intéressant et ça va être sympa à
regarder
je pense que ça va intéresser pas mal de
monde et on va avoir plus de deux
visiteurs etc
ça va faire découvrir des beaux
monuments comme le château de versailles
à versailles à versailles même je sais
pas enfin
jura pas d'événement athlétique sur
versailles ce mais ça sera sans doute
pas loin ça peut permettre aussi à des à
des jeunes de chez nous dès d'aller voir
en fait un championnat de très très haut
niveau ça redonnerait un peu des
couleurs à notre ville au sport ça
encouragera par versailles et ce serait
bien de pouvoir rencontrer des athlètes
qui nous montrera un peu l'exemple
alors comme on l'a entendu jean-marc
fresnel tout le monde est très
enthousiaste à l'idée de recevoir les
jeux olympiques
ici à versailles tout à fait moi je
trouve que alors c'est vrai que c'est
des fois on peut se dire à mme nous -
mois est issu du monde sportif dès qu'on
a eu cette candidature qui commençait à
prendre corps et c'est bien sûr on est à
fond dedans comme vous et c'est autour
de nous soit des élus soit la population
de 1024 c'est un peu loin etc
il ya des exemples qui ont montré que
les jeux étaient pas forcément porteur
que d'engouement etc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la candidature a pris
corps la population aussi a compris que
c'était une belle candidature qui était
basée sur des vraies valeurs des grandes
valeurs sportives etc
pas forcément sur de l'argent du
business comme ça peut l'être avec
d'autres pays que nous avions les
installations que certes celle qu'il n'y
avait pas main
elle était nécessaire donc c'est plutôt
bien et puis l'association de de la
france ville historique emblématique des
jeux pour nous versailles ville
historique
toutes les épreuves qui vont se faire
dans le centre de paris sont sur des
sites magnifiques et je pense que c'est
ce qu'a voulu aussi mettre en valeur la
comité d'organisation c'est que ses
associés la culture le passé le
patrimoine de paris à cette candidature
et non pas on fait des stades tout neufs
dans un coin etc c'est réservé aux
sportifs et les jeunes aussi qui sont
derrière nous peut-être qu'ils
participeront aux jeux olympiques de
2024 alors exactement en plus la ccl en
tout cas j'espère qu'il y en aura
comme j'espère bien oui il y en aura des
jeunes et puis je fais moi j'ai pas
encore vu les jeux dans mon pays donc
une blessure on les voit la télévision
aujourd'hui il ya des moyens
extraordinaires les images sont
magnifiques mais être dans une ambiance
à l'image des différents championnats du
monde qu'on peut avoir ici en france
c'est quand même extraordinaire et je
pense que tous ces jeunes qui ont une
vingtaine d'années dans cette en disant
non c'est pour toute leur vie qui vont
avoir le souvenir et du coup au niveau
du du projet vous le disiez donc il
risque d'avoir les épreuves d'équitation
le cyclisme sur route est ce qu il yad
autres épreuves qui sont au programme ou
pas pour l'instant est ce que le dossier
peut évoluer non enfin le dossier très
quand même bien ficelé les épreuves qui
sont sur tout le secteur épreuves
équestres autour d'eux
vous venez d un concours complet le
dressage le saut d'obstacles et c'est
par équipes et individuel on se fait
beaucoup d'épreuves plus le pentathlon
qui est assis pour les cinq épreuves via
une épreuve de cheval non la base c'est
forcément au même endroit que se trouve
le cheval et puis les autres épreuves
les ca des quatre autres épreuves se
décline autour donc notamment la
natation une potentielle pas encore trop
le lieu exact mais qui sera de toute
façon dans l'environnement immédiat de
lait des projets qu'istres et puis
toutes les épreuves de cyclisme sur
route contre la montre et par équipes
hommes et femmes dont ça fait quand même
déjà quatre épreuves puisque le
contre-la-montre partira de paris boucle
dans paris et arrivera à versailles
devant le château formidable comme
arrivée et l'épreuve en ligne fera le
même circuit des quais le premier
première arrivée à versailles après soit
suivie de quatre boucles en vallée de
chevreuse on repense à chaque fois à
versailles et ensuite partiront à paris
pour avoir une configuration type tour
de france
dernière question jean mach fresnel on a
combien de % de chance d'accueillir ces
choses là qui 2024 selon vous ah non je
vais pas répondre comme ça parce que ce
soit d'abord on a vraiment un principe
du comité température c'est de ne jamais
se comparer de ne pas parler de l'autre
c'est de valoriser ce qu'on est de
montrer qu'on a on ne critique pas
l'adversaire et on critique pas
l'adversaire donc dire si on a la chance
car ça voudrait dire que c'est une sorte
de critique
donc c'est pas le principe puis moi de
toute façon l'un vraiment à titre
personnel je crois que les deux dossiers
moi j'ai regardé chez moi hier soir le
dossier de los angeles
le dossier est costaud il est bien il
est complètement différent donc après ça
va d'autres types d'enjeux ça peut être
pu les monts du cio ils ont ils ont leur
propre réflexion etc
je pense que on a un dossier solide on a
un dossier qui a une grande cohérence on
a un dossier comme le jeu d'évoquer tout
à l'heure qui est basée sur notre
patrimoine qui a été valorisée autour de
ça ça c'est une bonne chose et surtout
surtout qui est porté par les athlètes
est porté par mouvement sportif
j'étais à paris encore ce matin
c'est avant tout ceux qui sont mis en
avant ses débuts comme teddy riner marie
josé pérec ou donne estanguet donc c'est
des gens comme ça qui qui portent en eux
des vrais aux fortes valeurs de ce sport
et c'est cela qui montre vraiment ce
qu'est la france sportive
merci jean marc fresnel et encore un
grand bravo pour cette année sans qui ce
passe grc merci beaucoup
nous venons donc de faire un point sur
ce dossier versailles est cette fois ci
au sein de la candidature paris 2024 est
ce qu'il ya des échanges entre les
différentes agglomérations à ce que
saint quentin en yvelines travaille de
concert avec versailles par exemple eh
bien je pense que nous attendons
certainement le 13 septembre pour
permettre les échanges avec
effectivement l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc et parler
globalement des différentes épreuves
nous n'avons pas encore de contact très
très marquée encore avec nos amis
versailles et à l'est puisque vous avez
parlé du 13 septembre
terminons cette émission sur cette
journée cette soirée d'annoncé du 13
septembre au vélodrome au sein du
vélodrome il y aura des animations
devant également sur le pari est toute
une série d'animations seront prévus et
puis nous vivrons ensemble puisque tv
fils sera présent pour vous
retransmettre et vous faire vivre ce
moment de l' annonce et on l'espère le
dénouement sera heureux sur ctv 78 il me
semble avoir dit encore une fois
téléfilm gervais revoir les plans pour
répéter à la rentrée je serai
opérationnel là-dessus aura pas de souci
donc sur tv 78 cette journée du 13
comment va-t-elle se dérouler au
vélodrome alors la journée du 13 va se
dérouler en deux grandes parties
importantes et il apprend tout lignée
que cette journée est tellement organisé
par saint quentin en yvelines qui pilote
vraiment l'organisation qui a souhaité
faire de cette journée un temps très
très fort pour le territoire pour le
territoire et pour l'olympisme pas
uniquement le cyclisme on sera au
vélodrome national certes mais lors du
vélo durera du golfe y aura du foot y
aura du tennis y aura beaucoup de choses
ça va durer toute la journée une grande
partie de la journée avec des jeunes
avec des scolaires pour une fois encore
préparer l'avenir c'est important les
sensibiliser aux sports et puis une
partie de soirée
la très importante puisque ce sera ce
sera le compte à rebours avant l'annoncé
officielle on n'a pas encore l'heure
at mais ça se passera donc dans le
vélodrome ce sera retransmis sera à son
maximum en l'a retransmis sur les écrans
géants et dans la tente de la
retransmission il y aura un certain
nombre d'animations à l'intérieur du
cyclisme mais pas que des surprises qui
sont en préparation peut pas encore tout
vous dire mais on reviendra peut-être
vous en parlait justement ça se déroule
à la rentrée donc voilà une très très
belle fête du sport en perspective le 13
septembre à saint quentin en yvelines au
vélodrome nationale était né et élevé 78
bien implanté au sein du vélodrome et
pour retransmettre tout ça pour saint
quentin en yvelines ce sera un moment
important grave ou travailler dessus
aussi
mais nous travaillons oui il ya
énormément dessus et arnaud a déjà
dévoilé un peu le le contenu de cette
journée du 13 septembre qui est très
très important qui est une journée bien
sûr très importante nous aurons comme
arnaud la préciser un point sur
l'essentiel de la matinée et puis en
début d'après-midi avec 800 jeunes
environ qui seront répartis en ateliers
avec les différentes activités sportives
nous aurons et je dévoilerai pas tout
mais quelques éléments avec un pool
effectivement cyclisme mes impôts le
golfe
et puis également d'autres activités
olympiques qui seront comme thème des
différentes
classe qui viendront et c'est en
partenariat avec l'urss le sport
scolaire le également le comité
départemental olympique du sport
français
et puis également d'autres partenaires
le scolaire et puis ensuite il ya une
deuxième
une deuxième partie plus festive et plus
grand public avec non dévoilé le dirais
pas je ne dirais pas mais ce sera donc
un événement grand public un événement
festif en attente de la candidature qui
devrait venir vers 21h 22h à en fin de
journée au vélodrome
donc c'est une journée de fête jusqu'au
rien d'autre d'autres sportifs également
de haut niveau qui seront également en
notre compagnie au vélo donc ça tous les
trois c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale jo-2000 24 en attendant la
décision du cio
donc le 13 septembre à lima et vous
pourrez suivre l'annoncé cette décision
en direct sur notre antenne à partir de
17 heures soirée spéciale depuis le
vélodrome donc 2 saint quentin en
yvelines où de nombreuses animations
seront prévues et deux victoires
à l'arrivée je l'espère merci wilfried
rendez vous prochainement sur tv 78 à
bientôt
[Musique]